about very well in terms of the
circulation of the virus
the government dropping the risk level
from four
to three today
but not at risk of rising exponentially
so that also good news so it looks like
we're all on track
to have a really good unlocking uh next
week so what might the prime minister
talk about well i've got um
the details here from step three not
before the 17th of may this was outlined
in that road map at the beginning of the
year so let's see what he says
if it all goes according to plan from
next week we should be able to
meet indoors either six of us together
or two households
you should be able to have gatherings of
30
outside in the garden you can have a
celebration
there will be also indoor entertainment
should be opened up so maybe we can all
go to
the cinema again there'll be information
on that
information too on venues opening up
entertainment venues and hostels and
hotels and also
overnight stage you you could go and
stay with someone
overnight around the country and then of
course look what he says about
social distancing will we able to touch
each other again will the guidelines
change
so that we can have closer physical
contact
with people updates on that now uh
that's all the positive news where is
the pressure coming from well it's
coming again from a group of
conservative
mps that would like the prime minister
to go faster they argue that if it's
about data not dates then the data
points to a speeding and up of the lock
unlocking that actually
could he go further and could he go
faster and certainly
mark harper that leads that group has
been calling for all social
distancing to be ended by june the 21st
in pubs
they'll be open but will we all have to
stand a meter apart how will that affect
businesses so
mps will be looking to see if there
could be some acceleration
of that so i think plenty of good news
uh
to come in a few moments beth it's mark
austin here now um
it's uh coming up to five o'clock and as
you say we're expecting uh
boris johnson any moment in fact that's
very well timed because here he is let's
have a listen
thanking everyone again for your
patience and for the sacrifices
that you've been making businesses pubs
restaurants that have been waiting to
welcome customers back through their
doors
grandparents who have gone for months
without seeing their grandchildren
weddings postponed funerals sadly
constrained and religious festivals
such as eid yet again facing
restrictions
and i want to thank you particularly
because your efforts
have so visibly paid off giving us the
time to vaccinate
more than two-thirds of all adults
across the uk
with more than one-third nearly 18
million people
also receiving their second dose
and thereby unquestionably saving
many lives and so it's precisely because
of your efforts
that i can confirm today that we've met
our four tests for further easing the
lockdown
in england and chris will run through
the details
in a minute but with deaths and
hospitalizations at their lowest level
since last july
the and the uk's four chief medical
officers today
agreeing a reduction in the alert level
the data
now support moving to step three in
england from next monday the 17th of may
this means the rule of six or two
households that is applied
outdoors will now apply indoors
and the limit for outdoor meetings will
increase to 30
from next monday you'll be able to sit
inside a pub and inside
a restaurant you'll be able to go to the
cinema and children
will be able to use indoor play areas
we're reopening
hostels hotels bmbs
we'll reopen the doors to our theaters
concert halls and business conference
centers
we'll unlock the turn styles of our
sports stadia
subject to capacity limits and from next
week
everyone will be able to travel within
britain
and stay overnight meaning schools will
also be able
to organize trips with overnight stays
we will no longer require face coverings
in classrooms
or for students in communal areas in
secondary schools and
colleges all remaining university
students
will be able to return to in-person
teaching
where they should be tested twice a week
we will increase the number of named
visitors for those in care homes from
two to five
and residents will have greater freedoms
to leave their home
without having to isolate on their
return
this unlocking amounts to a very
considerable step on the road back
to normality and i am confident that we
will be able
to go further subject to the impact of
step three on the data
we remain on track to move to step four
on the 21st of june and to give
business more time to prepare we'll be
saying more
later this month about exactly what the
world will look like and what role there
could be
if any for certification and social
distancing
and today we're taking a step towards
that moment
when we learn to live responsibly with
covid
when we cease eventually to rely on
detailed government edicts and
make our own decisions based on the best
scientific advice about
how to protect our families and those
around us
so from next monday we're updating the
guidance
on close contact between friends and
family
setting out the risks for everyone to
make
their own choices this doesn't mean we
can suddenly
throw caution to the winds in fact
more than a year into this pandemic we
all know
that close contact such as hugging is a
direct way
of transmitting this disease so i urge
you to think about the vulnerability
of your loved ones whether they've had a
vaccine
one or two doses and whether there has
been time
for that vaccine to take effect
remember outdoors is always safer
than indoors and if you're meeting
indoors remember to open a window and
let in the fresh air
keep getting tested regularly even if
you don't have symptoms
so you don't spread the virus without
knowing it
and whatever you decide i must
ask you to continue to follow social
distancing
when not with friends and family
including in workplaces
shops pubs restaurants
and other settings we only have to look
at the very sad situation
in other countries to see the lethal
potential still
of this virus and we must continue to
fight the spread of variants
here in the uk while we have
no evidence yet to believe that these
variants
are completely vaccine resistant we must
remain vigilant so
please remember hands face space
and fresh air and as we mark
mental health awareness week perhaps
also
take a moment to check in on friends and
family
and see how they are doing after all
that we have been through
together or if you're struggling
yourself
get the support that you need
today we are announcing
the single biggest step on our roadmap
and it will allow us to do many of the
things
that we've yearned to do for a long time
so let's protect these gains
by continuing to exercise caution
and common sense thank you and over to
chris
thank you prime minister um the
ministers
actually set out four tests for moving
between the stages
and i'd just like to lay out the data
behind each of these tests first slide
please
so the first test was that the vaccine
deployment program
continues successfully and i think it's
very clear
to everybody in the uk that this has
been very successful a steady rollout
for people for their first vaccinations
so we now have
just over two-thirds of people have had
a first
vaccine in terms of adults and
just over a third of adults have had a
second vaccine already
starting with the most vulnerable and
this continues thanks to the
extraordinary efforts
of the nhs next slide please
the second test was that evidence
continues to show
that vaccines are sufficiently effective
at reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated there
were original
trial data we now have very clear data
from real world settings
and some of that was published further
data was published
by public health england today and this
shows that there is somewhere between a
55 and 70
reduction uh in terms of symptomatic
disease for people who've had a first
vaccine
around a 75 to 85 percent reduction
uh in terms of hospitalization uh and
uh a around a seventy five to eighty
percent reduction
in the chance of someone dying after
they've had the first vaccine
we also have data particularly from the
pfizer uh vaccine
it's accumulating for a zed which we
started to roll out
uh slightly later uh demonstrating that
the second dose
significantly further increases the
protection
so that over 90 percent and possibly
over 95 percent
of people protection for people from
death
if they have that vaccine so this is uh
undoubtedly this test has been
met next slide please
there is however an important uh point
to make on this
uh and that is that uh we know that the
mortality
the chance of dying and the chance of
having severe disease
is much more weighted towards people who
are older
or have pre-existing health conditions
and what in
on the left-hand side of this graph what
we have is over the period this pandemic
the total number of people who have
sadly died of kovid
in england and what you can see is the
red line demonstrates
the age group to which we've got so uh
the majority of people in every age band
over the age of 40 have now had a first
vaccine
and a significant proportion of those at
the top end of this have had a second
uh boosted dose and they have got a lot
of protection but remembering
this protection is not 100 but on the
right what you see is the total number
of people
who actually have cases of covid and
what this shows
is that a substantial proportion of the
people who catch kovid
and some of whom will get significant
long-term problems themselves
but also who transmit kovid have not yet
been vaccinated this tells us
a very positive thing that a lot of
protection to those who are most
vulnerable
but additionally it makes clear why it
is that if we go too fast
at this stage when things have gone so
well thanks to the efforts of the entire
population that there is a risk of
significant spread
amongst those in the younger age groups
next slide please the third test is that
infection rates do not
risk a surge in hospitalizations that
would put unsustainable pressure on the
nhs
and as the prime minister has said the
view of all the chief medical officers
for england scotland wales and northern
ireland
and of the medical director of the nhs
based on advice from jbc is not only
that rates
in hospital are very low which uh we can
see in this graph
showing there's been a steady decline
and the number of people who've dying
from covid
is now very small indeed thankfully in
the uk
but that we do not think there is a
likelihood
in the next period after this upsurge of
seeing a significant increase in
pressure on the nhs
although some increase in transmission
should be assumed
as a result of the opening up that the
prime minister has
has laid out next slide please
the final test and in a way the most
difficult test
is the assessment of the risk um from
variance of concern
these are uh new variants of kovid
which might be one or other or both of
either more transmissible than existing
ones and
everyone in the country will remember
that when the b117 variant
first started emerging in kent it then
spread incredibly fast so more
transmissible ones are potentially a
problem
or ones which could cause problems with
vaccination
and we do have some confidence
that the vaccines we have provides a
reasonable degree of protection
from severe disease but that can be
reduced with
some of the existing variants including
uh the one
b1351 first described in south africa
uh but others could emerge or we might
get more transmissible ones and we have
uh a concern at the moment about a
variant uh
called b1 617.2 rather snappy uh
uh name uh first described from india uh
and
this uh is actually uh spreading from
very small amounts uh
but it is beginning to spread in certain
parts of the country and we need to keep
quite a close eye on this so the point
about this is
the threats are significantly reduced
but there are still
some residual issues that we need to
keep a very close eye on and therefore
we need to go carefully
and steadily as the prime minister has
said
thanks very much chris uh patrick we're
going to add this at this stage then
let's go to
members of the public and from york
what proportion of recent daily
infections
is found to come from variants of
concern other than the kent variant
uh chris i think i'm going to pass that
one
to to you yes the um the numbers in
terms of
actually how many there are are were in
the last slide so i think people may
want to look at the exact numbers
the proportions at the moment are less
than five percent uh our variants are on
uh which are the um not the b117 the uh
kent variant which is the dominant one
in the uk but
uh that's changing the whole time most
of them are currently relatively stable
they're not increasing at a great rate
the one that is uh slightly concerning
us in terms of increasing is the
proportion
uh is uh the the variant uh which has
been described from india
and that is in certain parts of of the
uk
and that does appear to be increasing
but from very low levels
over the last uh two weeks
thanks very much anne uh thank you chris
francis from lincoln
with the road map set to open up for
physical
contact e.g hugs from the 17th of may
how are you planning to protect the
unvaccinated
under 40s teachers and support staff who
will undoubtedly feel the consequences
of this
well francis thank you very much and i
know there's going to be a lot of people
thinking about the uh the
guidance on hugging and how if at all
they should
uh they should respond and i would i
would say that people
as i said in my earlier remarks people
should
uh obviously you you should you should
do it if you think it's appropriate if
you think
uh there's uh the risks are very very
low
but uh you should exercise care and
common sense and clearly
uh with uh unvaccinated people uh
there must be a a greater risk of
transmission
uh than those who have had vaccination
but there again
don't forget francis that uh even with
two doses of of the vaccine although you
will be at
much less risk of uh of death or
of hospitalization uh there is still a
risk of
of transmission even though it's greatly
reduced so basically
uh francis it's up to all of us to
exercise
common sense and and caution in the way
we we do it
uh let's go to hugh pim of the bbc
thank you prime minister is it possible
that you might even bring
forward the june the 21st date for the
final stage of the
road map and the lifting of all legal
restrictions or will you
definitely stick to that as the earliest
possible time
hugh i i i think it's very important
that we
should proceed uh cautiously
uh but as i as i've said many times now
uh
hopefully irreversibly and the the
secret of the
success that we've had so far i think
has been that we have been guided by the
the data and we've given time to see the
effect of each successive
stage on the on the roadmap so from uh
march the 6th to april the 12th and then
april the 12th to may the 17th and then
on to june the 21st
we've given ourselves a breathing space
what's happening today or what's
happening on
monday the 17th everybody understand is
a very considerable
unlocking and uh there will be
uh a lot of uh of extra movement a lot
of
uh a lot of extra uh contact that's just
inevitable
from what's happened we think we can we
can do it
but it's got to be done in a in a way
that's uh that's cautious and i think
we'll want to
have time to to see the effect you've
heard what chris has said about the
presence of the
of the indian variant and other variants
we've just got to monitor these things
as we go along and i think what business
would want to see
uh getting ready for the 21st is as much
certainty
about that as possible and and that's
what we we aim to deliver
thank you very much hugh romilly weeks
of itv prime minister
now you're telling people to use their
own judgment on hugging given that it is
a significant
factor in the spread of kobit are you
expecting people to be extremely
cautious about who
and how often they hug if i can also ask
who you're looking forward to hugging
and last week you said there was a good
chance we could scrap
social distancing rules all together
after june the 21st
the scientists doing the modeling
suggests we have no idea what will
happen if that is done
would that really be a wise move in that
case
uh thanks very much romilly well i i
just repeat what i said i think
um and whoever i uh i can assure you it
will be done with caution and
uh and restraint uh i'm i'm not going to
to
you know act it out now uh but uh i
think we all know
uh what what we mean it's it's about
basic uh common sense and when it comes
to
um uh social distancing from
from june the 21st um i i look at the
data very carefully and i i think at the
moment
it looks to me as though we may we may
be able
to dispense with the one meter plus rule
that's not yet decided it's not yet
clear we'll have to
we'll have to wait and see but it's it's
by being prudent
and being cautious that we've been able
to make the the progress that
that we have as i say we'll be saying
more to everybody more to business
uh to give everybody as much clarity as
we can about how they should prepare
uh by the end of this month getting
ready for for june the 21st uh chris or
patrick again you want to add to on the
on on the great hugging uh question i'll
i'll answer on on the question about
this the post
june 21st i mean what the modelers have
done is made an assumption that stump
still some residual reduction in
transmission
and that's due to a number of things
hopefully better ventilation
there'll still be people who are working
from home who can work from home
and it's right for their business to do
so there will still be behaviors that
will all
demonstrate which means that contacts
probably won't be back
to pre-pandemic levels so on average
pre-pandemic
adults and children roughly 11 contacts
per day
currently it's down to about four or so
for adults so it will probably remain
down for a while to come
it's important that we continue to
isolate if positive
or with symptoms that's really really
important
to reduce the number of people out in
circulation
who are um potentially able to pass the
virus on
and then you know there may be other
things as well required in certain
circumstances and it may be
you know as winter comes and uh if rates
went up again
things like um covering face coverings
on transport might be necessary but this
is that first tranche of things that
first group of things that are really
important
in terms of keeping down the levels
and those aren't big impositions on any
of us that a what we're going to do
probably in terms of how we interact
with each other
and b things like the ventilation the
ability to still
stay working from home if it's
appropriate to do so
thanks very much romilly uh tom newton
done times radio
thank you prime minister uh question to
all three of you
if i may i'm working from home i know
you're going to give business time to
you you said that but so that they can
start to think about it now
is working from home going to go as
terms of guidance on june the 21st
or should people be thinking about that
continuing through the summer
through the autumn potentially even uh
through christmas and
prime minister uh you won't say who
you'll hug first but who will you shake
hands with first and when are you going
to
start shaking hands again you won't want
to ask to stop shaking hands maybe
who are you going to shake hands with
when you're allowed to where will that
be
uh tom on all that we're going to be
giving
as i said uh i i mean i don't want to be
a you know uh
i don't know your question's a very good
one but i think we're going to wait and
give you
uh more detail and more guidance about
exactly what we mean by the end of
uh of of social distancing uh
later this month uh i'm optimistic that
things will
get you know back much closer to
normality
let me put it like that but clearly
people are going to continue to want to
exercise their own
judgment their own discretion uh for for
for a long while to come
um that's but uh you you'll hear a lot
more by the end of this month about
exactly what
the world after june the 21st is going
to look like at the moment
i'm feeling very positive about it but
we've got to be we've got to be guided
by the data
anything to add on that thank you very
much jason groves daily mail
all right thanks prime minister um can i
say scientists
given the uh excellent data we're
getting on the
uh the success of the vaccines
could this now potentially be the last
lockdown
uh that we see borrowing uh the
emergence of any
terrible new variant uh and prime
minister
can i just pick you up on that uh last
point you you've
you've said in the past
that you would like to see uh people
back at their desks at the
end of all this is that is that how you
see the future do you think people can
work as effectively there or
or is working from home got a big part
to play in the future still
um last lockdown to chris patrick well
i mean as the prime minister said this
is a big step that's being taken now
step three lots of things are starting
up again
over the next month there'll be many
more people vaccinated so
the balance is between opening up and
getting enough people vaccinated to be
protected so it's important that we
don't get out of step with that and go
ahead of ourselves
i think things are really pointed in the
right direction we'll have a much
clearer idea of the effects of step
three in mid-june so we'll know what
effect that's had
but everything is pointed in the
direction that the vaccines are
producing
very effective reduction in
hospitalizations and deaths
as chris has said we know that they're
also reducing onward transmission
all of that points to this now being a
much smoother path it points to
a lower increase than you might
otherwise have expected with another
wave
and things you know if they carry on
without variance are definitely pointed
in the right direction
yeah and jason on your uh
your point about what's the world gonna
look like are people gonna get back to
work do we want people to get back to
work well
i just remember uh when i was when i was
running tf i think i made this point
before observing a sudden a sort of
paradox of
of of transport which is that the more
people can
communicate remotely with brilliant uh
electronic devices the more
able they are to to meet other people
over the internet or
through the ether the more reasons they
actually
find to meet face to face
and uh i'm pretty certain and i know
this is
contested but i'm pretty certain that
eventually uh our town centers are going
to be
uh our city centers are going to be full
of bustle uh full of people
wanting to interact again in the way
that they always have done
now i might be i might be mistaken in
that belief
but uh i've a long experience of
watching the way uh great metropolis
operate um leads me to suppose that that
is what will
uh what will happen uh said payne of the
financial times
thank you very much prime minister and
what you've announced today suggests
that the pandemic is beginning to become
under control and we may be past the
worst of the crisis
do you where do you think it would be
reasonable and not irresponsible then
for scotland
to hold a second independence referendum
and for professor
witty um your side showed that the
number of cases of the indian variant
have doubled
in the last week are you at all
concerned this could destabilize the eat
lockdown easing plans and could lead to
a further lockdown in the autumn
well seb on your first point i had good
conversations with all the
uh heads of the devolved administrations
and
uh i can tell you everybody was resolved
that the number one priority for
uh the whole of the uk was to
build back better uh come out of the
coronavirus pandemic and build that
better
uh together um on the indian variant
in fact there are currently three indian
variants but the one that we're worried
about at the moment in the uk is the
617.2
it is it has gone up very sharply and i
think that's a reason for us uh to
be very careful about it and there's a
lot of work being done by public health
england
to try and delineate where it is and to
work out ways we by testing and
isolation we can get that on top of this
is to get on top of the curve of that
india has also gone into the red list
which means that
new people coming in would have been
significantly uh reduced
but i think what you you know in answer
to both your question and to the
previous one
what we know is with all the variants
that things can come out of a blue sky
uh you're not expecting it and then
something happened that happened uh
obviously with the b117
uh and that has happened to india uh
with this
uh variant as well so i think we we
would be very
improved to say it is impossible i think
at this point in time
i think our view is that this is a
highly transmissible variant
at least as transmissible as the b117
variant
it is possible it is more transmissible
but we'll have to see
uh at this point in time uh at the
at this point in time our view is it is
less
likely to be able to escape vaccination
than some of the other variants because
left one but the data are not properly
in there so i think it is you know we
need to be
cautious until we've seen clear data
that give us an answer one way or the
other
that the reason i've given that is a
relatively technical answer is of course
we don't know
whether this is going to cause
significant problems in the autumn the
way to deal with that is
identify the cases which have been
happening isolate where we can
which is also happening get through the
rest of the vaccination program
and ensure that we have the capacity to
pick these up
and also to re-vaccinate as necessary
when the autumn comes
the final point on this is the way to
prevent
minimize the number of variants that
circulate is obviously get on top of
this as a global problem
and that's something which all of us are
absolutely determined to support
thanks very much seb uh adam bienkov of
business insider minister you were on
record as opposing the last labor
government's plans
for compulsory photo id cards which you
described as a recipe for tyranny and
oppression
why therefore you're now planning to
bring forward in the queen's speech
legislation which will force
all voters to carry photo id in order to
vote and given the fact that there was
just a single conviction in the entire
country for in-person voter fraud at the
last general election
and given the studies show that labour
voters are much less likely to possess
photo id
than conservative voters what do you say
to people who suggest this is median
attempt to suppress the votes of people
who may not vote for the conservative
party uh
adam i would say that was complete
nonsense uh and what we want to do
is to protect democracy the transparency
and the integrity of the electoral
process and i don't think it's
unreasonable to ask
first-time voters to produce uh some
evidence of
of identity so that's the uh that's the
reason
okay everybody thank you very much
indeed thank you
so there we are the prime minister there
saying that uh
the england has met the tests for easing
lockdown
and the country will move to step three
from the 17th of may
so indoor hospitality reopens sports
stadia can welcome back
uh crowds subject to capacity limits um
travel can resume with limits masks
can go in schools he said students can
return in person to
university and he also talked quite a
lot about from next monday more personal
responsibility on close contact with
friends and family so hugging is back as
he said but
um he also sounded a note of caution on
personal responsibility he said outdoors
always better than indoors
when with other people but he did say it
was the
biggest step the single biggest step
on um the country's roadmap and he
thanked the public
and he said your efforts have visibly
paid off let's speak to our political
editor beth rigby
who was listening to all that so beth
um largely good news and as he says
a big step for the country
yes that's right mark everything going
to plan if anything the data looks a bit
better than they would have hoped you
heard it there over two-thirds of adults
have now
had a vaccination and 18 million people
across the country have had a double
vaccination now so had the two
jabs and uh sir patrick there talking
about uh
the vaccination program reducing
hospitalizations also
reducing transmission so hope that
really we are now
in a serious way going to be able to get
back uh to normal
and i i thought a really big moment
there was the prime minister when he
said
the time is coming when we cease to rely
on detailed government edicts
to make our own decisions you know he is
a libertarian
he seems to have had to ditch that
particularly after that kent
variant in december with a very strict
uh lockdown for much of this year and
and
extreme caution uh coming out of it um
but from next week life really does
come back to much more like a normal so
you'll be able to stay overnight at
people's houses you can have your family
and some friends around your table six
people
can mix indoors two households can mix
indoors outside you can have
30 people gathering and then when it
comes to personal contact well it's your
choice he says
if you want to hug people that's up to
you when he was asked to he
would hug he didn't say who it would be
but he did say he would proceed
with caution so all very good news i
think the only
slight cloud there the only cause of
concern was
uh professor witte on that indian
variant let me just pick up what he
said he said that the indian variant was
beginning to spread
in parts of the country we need to keep
an eye on it he stressed that it was
from a very low level uh and he's
also stressed that he thought that
testing could keep
on top of it but he also said this what
we know about variants
is that they can come out of blue sky at
this point in time
the engine variant is highly
transmissible at least as transmissible
as the kent variant if not more
but then he said he thought it was less
likely to be able
to escape vaccination of course this is
all work in progress they still have
limited data so
just a few concerns there this is the
big unpredictability
about ease in lockdown that you can
control what you know
but what is the big unknown is whether
other variants
emerge which could force the government
to have to change plans but for now
all on track for may the 17th and indeed
for june
the 21st as well step four and on the
matter of social distancing whether the
one point the one plus
meter rule will be dropped from june the
21st for indoor hospitality
uh and whether we will need those
covered passports
uh the prime minister said that he was
looking at all of that and he would
update us later in the month
yeah and it's interesting beth isn't it
that allowing
indoor mixing i mean the step that we're
about to take was always the step that
worried
the scientists um vaccines obviously
have
clearly made a big difference but they
were still you know sounding a note of
caution and this whole idea of
you know yes you can hug but not for
long and you know preferably outside and
all this so it
puts a lot of emphasis on personal
responsibility
yes mark i was talking to a cabinet
minister about this quite recently about
what they thought would happen at
step three and there's a sort of
understanding or expectation in
government that you will see another
increase in cases that there will be
another
mini wave what the vaccination program
suggesting is
that that won't be perhaps as big a wave
as perhaps
a little while ago people expected but
jason groves from the the
daily mail asked exactly this question
given his excellent data on successive
vaccines
uh is this last lockdown bar in an
emergence of a new variant and sir
patrick on that said
everything suggests the vaccinations
reducing hospitalization
and circulation and things are
definitely pointing in the right
direction
but in terms of that irreversible path
out of lockdown yes on track
but you can't ever nail it on because
you don't know as i said about new
variants
and in terms of all of ours i think the
prime minister there was saying
please exercise personal responsibility
but
certainly when millions of people have
been vaccinated they will feel more
comfortable
in being in close to circulation i think
the message there was
think about who you are in close contact
with
and try to stick to that one meter plus
rule
in shops in pubs and in settings outside
your close family and friends
okay